christine villemin a tenté de se
suicider une semaine après avoir appris
qu'elle serait jugée en cour d'assises
pour le meurtre de son fils grégory la
jeune femme a absorbé la nuit dernière
une forte dose de tranquillisants elle
est maintenant dans un service de
réanimation
mais selon son avocat ses jours ne
seraient pas en danger
c'est vers 8 heures ce matin que
christine villemin et découverte
inanimée par sa grand mère chez qui elle
vit ici dans cette maison de petit mot
christine villemin n'étant pas descendu
prendre son petit déjeuner sa grand mère
inquiète gravit les quelques marches qui
mènent à la chambre de sa petite fille
au premier étage
christine villemin qui a abusé de
tranquillisants est allongé sur son lit
inconsciente
une ambulance l'a transportera quelques
minutes plus tard à l'hôpital de
lunéville
elle sera admis au service de
réanimation où l'on se refuse à
communiquer son état de santé
mais il semble que ses jours ne soient
pas en danger on pourrait penser que le
geste de christine villemin est lié à la
décision de renvoi aux assises prise
mardi dernier par la chambre
d'accusation de nancy vendredi christine
villemin écrit plusieurs lettres à sa
grand mère à son mari incarcéré à
saverne et à ses défenseurs
seul le contenu de la lettre adressée à
m robinet est connu il n'apporte aucune
réponse à la tentative de suicide
mais pour les défenseurs de christine
villemin ce geste est bien en relation
directe avec la décision de la chambre
d'accusation pressing ils m'ont décidé
hier soir de mettre fin à ses jours
elle a été sauvée une fois mais son
malheur demeure l'arrêt de mise en
accusation est toujours là au dessus
d'elle lui faisant craindre le pire
c'est la deuxième fois que la mère de
grégory met sa vie en danger en juillet
85 alors qu'elle venait d'être incarcéré
à la prison de metz queuleu elle avait
défié les autorités judiciaires en
observant une grève de la faim pour
obtenir sa libération
au bout de quelques jours sont les
conseils de son avocat elle avait
accepté de s'alimenter à nouveau
quelques jours plus tard elle était
remise en liberté